je vous annonce aujourd'hui tout à fait
officiellement que j'ai saisi le Conseil
supérieur des programmes pour qu'il
élabore des programmes sur le sujet nous
n'avons pas de programme il n'y a jamais
de programme en matière d'éducation à la
sexualité c'est une demande d'ailleurs
qui était faite régulièrement par les
associations ainsi par ainsi que par le
Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et je pense que
c'est une chose nécessaire que
l'établissement de programme par le
Conseil supérieur des programmes afin de
disposer de cadres clairs par niveau par
degré qui permet par cycle qui permettra
de mettre en place
sereinement cet enseignement il s'agit
d'organiser la continuité et la
progressivité des enseignements il
s'agit éventuellement de rassurer des
familles qui pourraient être inquiète ou
hostile
ce cadre clair va montrer que
l'éducation à la sexualité est un
enseignement qui doit être fait qui doit
être adapté bien sûr à l'âge des élèves
qui respectent les intimités et les
convictions dans une approche globale et
positive il permettra d'engager de
soutenir le dialogue entre les
personnels et les familles j'ai demandé
au Conseil supérieur des programmes de
réfléchir également au terme utilisé et
notamment pour nommer
cet enseignement faut-il par exemple
conserver le terme d'éducation à la
sexualité dans le premier degré dans le
second degré oui mais dans le premier
degré c'est une question que l'on peut
poser la mise en oeuvre de ce programme
s'accompagnera de ressources
pédagogiques cohérentes avec lui du
renforcement de la formation des équipes
pédagogiques de la mise en place d'un
comité de liaison avec les associations
qui interviennent dans les
établissements
et de l'élaboration de d'une
cartographie en quelque sorte des
associations susceptibles d'intervenir
dans les établissements scolaires